Marvel's "What If...?" is all about reimagining
the MCU as we know it.
Episode 1 saw Peggy Carter become the world's
first supersoldier instead of Steve Rogers,
while Episode 2 saw T'Challa as Star-Lord
instead of Peter Quill.
However, for Episode 3, it's more than just
a simple substitution.
The story revolves around the Avengers and
Nick Fury's quest to bring the group together.
Simply put, the question we're meant to ask
ourselves in this episode is, "What if the
Avengers never happened?"
"Wow.
So serious."
The episode primarily focuses on how the Avengers
are picked off one by one; even the strongest
and seemingly immortal ones get their tails
handed to them in one shocking death after
the next.
First, Tony Stark is killed by Natasha Romanoff
accidentally.
Then, Clint Barton inadvertently takes out
Thor, with the archer's death following in
a prison cell shortly after.
The Hulk is the next to meet his end in rather
gruesome death, and sadly, we say goodbye
to Natasha -- again -- as she's the last of
the group to bite the bullet.
For most of the episode, we wonder who is
the person behind these attacks, and while
they weren't exactly hiding in plain sight,
they were right in front of us the whole time.
"What a fascinating choice of words."
Natasha figures out the mysterious killer
after logging into some SHIELD files at a
public library.
She realizes that Hope Van Dyne had also logged
into the system, despite being dead for two
years.
After hearing Natasha screaming to him on
the phone that it's "all about Hope," Nick
Fury heads to the Wasp's gravesite, where
he's met by her father, Hank Pym.
Looking absolutely haggard, Hank is revealed
as the killer of all five Avengers.
We then get a small flashback of the deaths
of the would-be Avengers where we see tiny
little Hank in his Ant-Man outfit killing
all of the would-be superheroes — so the
fact that we couldn't see the killer the whole
time should have been a dead giveaway.
It turns out Hank is exacting revenge on SHIELD
for the death of his daughter, who, Fury explains,
died outside of Ukraine during a mission for
the agency.
Hank blames SHIELD for her death and decides
the appropriate revenge is killing five people,
wanting Fury to see everything he's worked
for regarding the Avengers die.
"You never cared about Hope!"
"I don't give a damn about any of 'em!"
In a shocking twist no one could see coming,
Fury takes down the man who killed five Avengers
— with the help of Loki.
The God of Mischief has already come to Earth
for vengeance after learning of Thor's death,
but Fury convinces him to give him more time
to find the killer.
With the help of Loki's magic, Fury has the
upper hand over Hank, and the latter is eventually
taken into custody.
Here is where we get to imagine what would
happen in the MCU if Hank killed five of the
six Avengers.
After Fury tells Loki to go back where he
came from, the trickster reveals he wants
to extend his stay on Midgard with a mischievous
grin.
We then see Loki give a speech at the United
Nations in New York City, where he appears
to have become the new leader of Earth.
Now it's time for a new group of heroes to
assemble to take down Loki, who is living
out the life he only could have dreamed of
in another reality.
"The Avengers fell before they had a chance
to rise.
May they rest in peace."
"They can.
But we won't."
As you watch the episode and the poor Avengers
get picked off one by one, you might wonder
where Captain America was.
Well, he was still doing time as a capsicle
under the ice.
Fury also puts a call out on his favorite
pager while dusting the snow off of Cap's
frozen shield.
At the end of the episode, Captain Marvel
pops in, ready for battle.
So we now have a team of two Avengers who
will take on Loki as he rules the world with
a loyal army of Asgardians behind him.
In this reality, things are vastly different
than we know them from the Infinity Saga timeline.
Knocking out Natasha, Thor, the Hulk, Iron
Man, and Hawkeye means only a few superpeople
and worthy SHIELD agents are left.
Based on this timeline and the story of Hope
Van Dyne and Hank Pym, we can assume that
Scott Lang is just a regular old criminal
and not Ant-Man.
The Winter Soldier is still out there somewhere,
but he likely won't be recruited into a new
Avenger team.
Spider-Man in this universe isn't around yet,
and the Guardians of the Galaxy have yet to
be formed.
T'Challa also hasn't taken on the mantle of
Black Panther, which means it's slim pickings
for Fury.
It looks like Loki might have a nice run as
ruler of Midgard for quite some time, but
Captain Marvel should be a worthy adversary
of the trickster.
Together with Steve Rogers, the pair might
be able to take him down, but only if Fury
can find them some strong sidekicks.
This episode really has us wondering what
it will take for the Watcher to get involved.
If killing five Avengers doesn't encourage
him to step in, what will?
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.